louis alexandra le challenge est grand et
maintenant pour l'avenir comment voyez-vous le
évolution rapide du mois de
patrimoine hispanique au québec
Je le vois, nous sommes nous avons fait le premier
mettre en scène l'athlète tactique du savoir
au parlement et nous sommes le deuxième
procéder à l'analyse préliminaire des
l'objectif de ce projet est la vision
objectif et nous fixons le
priorités plus tard pour
développer ce projet au mieux
manière la plus inclusive pour le
communauté hispanique et qu'il est vraiment
pluraliste pour tous
alejandra alexandra désolé bien bien
nous avons vraiment besoin de tout le monde comme moi
Je dis toujours que je fais ce que tu ne fais pas
tu fais ce que je ne fais pas ensemble
nous pouvons faire de grandes choses dans ce domaine
projet nous avons besoin de jours que l'autre
de l'autre parce que nous sommes hispaniques
nous avons besoin de tout est un grand défi
mais
Je crois que le sommeil est précieux et vaut la peine
dommage que nous travaillions ensemble
simplement qu'ils unifient ceux qui
peut contribuer à venir à nous
mais de toute façon nous allons
allez vers eux mais nous avons besoin de tout le monde
ok merci beaucoup merci beaucoup